how do you get to the point when you got
like a year here oh I saw David Bowie
it's was getting two before he
introduced you on stage yeah the one of
the at Madison Square Garden theater how
do you as that big of a fan not get
distracted and let it kind of take you
off your focus to know that David Bowie
is live not taped live on stage
introducing I was crazy how that
happened it was crazy
um I know okay I'll cover yeah that's
funny kind of a bit sort of my musical
hero for 25 years right and then I met
him I was sort of newly famous the
offices just gone out and I've got
invited to one of those VIP things of
the DBC there's now he playing to an
audience a few people that I smell was
one of them I went with a girlfriend
Jane went along and the then director
general for the BBC Greg Dyke afterwards
he bounced over to me and went you're a
huge Bali fan aren't ya I went yeah
loving economy going oh no knock on Liam
Oh went went off shows me quit Dyke I'm
a girlfriend and he shows Salman Salman
rusty joins us mental we went down and
knocked on valleys door and he opened it
was eating alone
hello Salman when that this is Jay King
James Heller no he didn't enjoy that he
is great it's just people I didn't know
oh oh I was I um spoke to the next day I
was in the problem I might if I might
say what'd you do last night and I went
nothing how do i how would I say
soundlessly in Bali why would you do and
so that was it and it was like oh my god
you know it's great and then suddenly he
definitely knew I was a week later I'd
get an email from David knowing he can
do that he was David bowing Wow
and he just said it just did it said
subject the office so someone had given
him box set he said I watched I laughed
what do I do now and that was it and we
sort of became pen pals and uh and then
you know whenever I was in America we
were honest I remember it was his
birthday was a - January and on this I
think was 57th
birthday I sent him an email
happy birthday up at 57 isn't it about
time you got a proper job Ricky Gervais
is comedian 42 he sent back I've got a
proper job David by Rockstar no and no
rock god and then I invited him we would
come over and we uh we went to see him
in his price at Downton and it's so
funny because I had to separate the two
really that I knew him and he was a
friend and he was my biggest Idol and it
was weird the first time we met him in
America went to his place and the dorm
went I had seen mr. Jones only a coolin
coolin bow bow he doesn't exist right
and he was so sweet and normal it was
just after his heart attack as well and
he was pretending to be I just made this
a cup of coffee that's what coffee went
made coffee right in the kitchen and he
came out sort of shaking pretending to
be doggery joking about his mortality
stuff and there was this big statue we
have a big sort of sort of pewter
Picasso a sort of staff to us amazing
even yeah the artist there he was trying
to do what Picasso did in 2d things
represent in 3d in 3d anyway my daughter
likes to hit that with a hammer very
funny and then I invited to do extras
which was great
oh yeah I sent the lyrics to him and I
said you got lyrics he went yeah yeah
yeah I said I'm can you do something
like I'm life on Mars you know he went
oh yeah
I'm not have a quick [ __ ] life on
Mars okay let's melt in that was dry it
was uh be double laser and then and he
said do you want to do a thing for the
High Line there was a it was a Madison
Square thing was a high one right of all
and I was my first gig in New York and I
went really
and I imagine kid it was for charity I
imagine it a lot of fundraiser
was all people in sort of bow ties and
stuff because it wasn't really just old
normal ticket certain right and them and
I said have you seen my stand-up I said
what should I do
he said anything you like he said as
long as it's delightfully offensive
lastly and he came out he came out as a
surprise the audience in [ __ ] mental
right and he comes out and he's got a
little harmonica anyway hmm
chubby little loser yeah it's great you
know really amazing yeah incredible